okay thanks it's microphone good
yep cool all right um so I'll just start
with a quick introduction about what
these two
at all talked about a little bit about
but actually most of the talk will be
much more general it's an ended up being
a bit more of an opinion piece so which
I actually often find more useful and
interesting than talks about like you
know the fine grained details of some
library so for the last few years have
been developing this open source library
spacey
and this really sprung out of the need
that I saw a library that took the types
of results which were rapidly being
generated in academia and I was working
on at a time and made them more
accessible for industry and then since
since soon after we launched that I
ended up founding a company with Ennis
Montana
I'll call explosion AI so in addition to
the library space II we have a machine
learning library that we use with it are
called think and an annotation tool
prodigy and soon enough we'll have a
data store of pre train models that will
be providing alongside Spacey as well so
is a sort of quick bio this is I'm
Matthew and that's my co-founder Ennis
and we're basically you know together
most pretty much all of Xplosion high so
we're a very small company based here in
Berlin that really just does a
commercial open source software so
there's the open source library and then
this commercial tool on top the
annotation tool prodigy so the way that
we often I explained the sort of
structure of these things and you know I
guess we didn't explain it like m5 or
often explain it like I'm senior
management the analogy that we use is
like a boutique kitchen so the free
recipes is kind of like the open source
software and then we started off to in
consulting to support ourselves but then
we've since switched over to this sort
of line of gadgets which is this thing
prodigy and other extensions as well and
soon we'll have premium ingredients that
we're selling with this okay so to move
into the talk proper I'll start with
this assertion so the assertion here is
that natural language processing
projects are like startups so they fail
a lot and so this is presented without
you know I'm not going to be pretend
scientific and give you like some survey
or something but we have seen this and
to give you a bit of an intuition for
why do this should be true or why it
make it seem a little bit more obvious
to you imagine what the world would look
like if NLP projects were not failing
regularly because human because human
language is the you know basically the
world's information system this really
underpins a lot of commercial activity
all over the place right and so if it
were true that these things didn't fail
often if it were true that we could
easily automate a lot of the work that
happens in back offices and then sort of
underpins its economic activity we would
be seeing a far far greater upswell in
growth of the natural language
processing projects and instead we do
see like plenty of growth in our inner
peers we do with other AI technologies
but it's nothing like what we would see
if if this were actually just easy and
if everything just worked out of the box
so and you know additionally if you use
these technologies like Translate or
interactive chat applications or search
or summarization things you'll see that
these technology is far from perfect and
so there's this little dance that needs
to be done to map those imperfections
and get those imperfect technologies
delivering useful enough value that
justifies a commercial thing investment
and when this works it works
fantastically well and so there's some
projects which basically return the fund
like they say for startups where you
know a few projects are wildly
successful but then there's still a lot
of failures so now the question is what
drives that frequency of failure and how
can we avoid it and how can we do better
and in particular how can we make sure
that your project isn't one of the ones
that fail well okay so to consider this
we can flip the question on its head and
say alright what would we what would it
look like if we wanted to maximize the
project's risk of failure well you know
here so I outlined some steps here so
step one would be you know really just
sit down and imaginary so decide what
you think your application ought to do
and you know don't really fuss too much
about what seems practical or what seems
likely to work just you know nobody
changed the world saying I'm not sure
that that's going to work so you know
that's step one and then feed that step
one forward into
a forecasting process so you know given
that given what you think you want your
application to do figure out what
accuracy we'll need to achieve your
dreams and if you're not sure just say
90% then you know the next step of our
you know recipe for failure would be
well okay now we're just going to
outsource this so you know we've thought
carefully about what accuracy want and
then you know fortunately we can use
that estimate to somehow figure out how
much data we want except we kind of
can't so let's just ask for 10,000
routers or something that should do and
then finally you know this is the good
part the part which we all think about a
lot for machine learning projects you
know it's time to wire everything up
time to implement the model time to
iterate and fit the model and like you
know do all of this good stuff so you
know this is the part which we all look
forward to and the part that really when
people talk about machine learning
projects this is the phase where you
know the story starts for most people
and then finally you know okay hopefully
we can integrate the thing into the
project and if it doesn't work then you
know I hope that we have some you know
four person who we can blame and an
intern might be a good target okay
so you know let's cartoonishly what you
know how does this actually work like
what's gone wrong here well and in
particular you know I don't want to have
this narrative that like well life is
hard failure happens often like life is
Unsoeld and we should just like accept
it I do think that there's a lot that we
can do to minimize this and so you know
how can we do better well we can start
both thinking more broadly about you
know what makes a successful machine
learning application and so here I've
sort of outlined a little hierarchy of
needs and at the base of the pyramid the
sort of like thing that you need most
the sort of basic comfort and security
female physical needs is understanding
how the model will work in the larger
application or the business process so
you know basically this is the planning
out of um what the model will do and
what need were trying to get met for it
and that design question of you know
what problem we're going to solve the
machine learning is really the
fundamental theme and if we can have
clarity about that then we can often
find ways to design the prose the
problems so that the problems will be
easier to solve from the machine
learning perspective so you know we can
make our lives easier and make sure to
live with getting technologies that it
will be we we're crafting the problem in
the weight of the technology can easily
meet so then the next step is to take
that business need and mapping into
annotation schemes and corpus
constructions so that we can decide what
the data should look like to actually
meet that to make the needs that we have
and in particular we want to make sure
that we're designing the annotation
scheme in a way that facilitates
consistent annotations and easy
decisions from the models and this is
actually a lot harder than it sounds
especially for natural language
processing because you end up kind of
trying to divide the world into this
ontology right and the world doesn't
actually go babies fix neat categories
and so there's tends to be quite an art
to actually coming up with annotation
schemes and refining them over time that
helps the data be collect consistently
annotated and it helps the model
actually do what you wanted to do and
then in addition as well as excellent
the annotation scheme there's an
implementation phase of the annotation
of you know sort of running the project
effectively so that you your annotators
know what they're doing so that they're
sort of reliably and consistently
incentivized to give you the sort of
annotations that you want to instead
you've got a good feedback loop through
this and also quality control processes
so all of these things define what the
problem you're going to be solving and
what data you're going to use to solve
and evaluate it and then finally on top
of that that's when we get to this sort
of fun bit of you know tensor and your
flows into sending your gradients of you
know deciding your model architectures
and things and then finally the
optimization as well and so the model
architecture and optimization parts
which you know the academic community in
a lot of the tutorials are focusing on
and this does make sense because in a
sense it it is kind of a limiting factor
that you know as a global community we
had better solutions to these things
overall projects would do better but in
any specific project that you're working
with it's very often the case of these
aren't the things that are going to
define success or failure it's very
often the earlier phases of this that
are going to take
and project from something that sort of
works or something that like really
doesn't so the problem here is that we
end up with this chicken and egg problem
so in order to sort of figure out the
product vision that we want we really
often need to know how accurate the
model is likely to be on that problem
that problem so there's a real
characteristic difference that will have
any weight if we design our application
if we imagine that the model will be say
95% accurate versus if it's only going
to be 80% accurate and those assumptions
and differences are going to we really
want to bake that back into the way that
the whole interaction flow is designed
for instance a Chad application is
probably not going to work very well at
all if we're making an error on every
utterance and you know the user has to
constantly ask for clarification if
that's going to be the case and we
probably want to design our application
differently
similarly for translation if the
translation in our language pair is
going to be pretty bad then we hope that
we could have a lot of dictionary back
offs and lots of like ways that we can
click on words to like you know help the
user puzzle out what's going wrong or
what to do if the translation is bad and
so these all these things about product
design really depend on the accuracy
estimate and the problem there is that
in order to get that sort of reasonable
accuracy estimate we have to start
making contact with the data we can't
really pluck this out of thin air and so
we need to like start running some
experiments we need to start doing some
training and evaluation and in or do
that we need to know what label data to
collect and in order to do that we need
to know how our annotations should look
but we don't really know how our
annotations should look if we don't know
what the model is supposed to do which
feeds back into the product vision so we
have this like you know this chicken and
egg problem of like what bit to solve
first in it in this and I think that
that actually drives a lot of a problem
here but okay so the solution here is
that we need to iterate on the whole
process we need to iterate on the code
that we're developing for this and the
model architecture in the optimization
but we also need to iterate on the data
that we are developing and the way that
we're framing the problems so you know
as we said like basically don't make
assumptions iterate at a more
fine-grained level and sort of start
going over to feedback loop more quickly
so we have to figure out what models
which
trained to meet the business needs and
then we have to be asking does the
annotation scheme make sense when we
start implementing it does and then once
we're doing that we can figure out
there's the problem look easy or hard
and then we can start moving back to the
business place and saying what can we do
in the application to improve the fault
tolerance so sort of figure out why this
is wrong awareness you know basically
let's start to look at where this might
go wrong and you know I think that this
is actually probably the most
interesting case of failure that I think
we've observed while running Spacey and
prodigy and doing our consulting
projects and I think it's one which
isn't easily do isn't often discussed so
when I say modeling decisions here I
really mean the way to business
requirements are mapped into a set of
statistical models so you know we're
going to have some statistical model or
combination models they're going to be
predicting things and if we start off
with a sort of need of output there's
often a wide variety of ways that we can
break that down into decisions so here
imagine that we want to build a crime
database and it's going to be so we're
going to be feeding it news reports and
we want to extract the following
information so we want to label things
like victim name the name of the
perpetrator if it's mentioned a crime
location if it's men engined
the date of the offense date of arrest
if it's mentioned all this sort of
information so this is what we want
output and that's what we want the sort
of system to do so so how should we
break that need down into one or more
machine learning models what and what
data should we annotate to train them
how should we evaluate them etc etcetera
so this is what really what I mean by
modeling decisions and the claim that
I'm making here is actually to these
decisions are incredibly important
really drive success or failure much
more than decisions about you know using
an ls2 canvas using a CNN or something
like that okay
so here's one obvious way to do it that
I'm going to suggest is probably pretty
on ideal so imagine that we're going to
be labeling these as you know basically
spans of text as victim and another span
of span of text as crime location and
we're going to basically phrase this as
an entity recognition
and we're going to train something like
a sort of standard entity recognition
model that's going to read the the text
and try to apply begin inside and labels
to these words so this coding clearly
will can meet the business need so it's
clear that you know if if a classifier
could reproduce these annotations
accurately we can use the annotations
that it's producing to meet what we need
the question is is this the best way to
frame the problems that it'll be cheap
to acquire the annotations and that the
model will perform accurately and I
suggested actually it's probably not so
here's an alternate way to think about
this instead so instead of having this
sort of annotation we might instead do
something like this and so we might
apply a bit of information across a
wider span of text so we do text
classification for crime and then we
might have a more generic person
location etc tagging and this doesn't
necessarily tag exactly the same eye
information so here for instance King
cross is tagged as the location as well
as East London because we're not joining
in the coding of the roles that we have
here like we're not trying to figure out
that East London was the the the
location of the crime at this phase of
it were just taggings location so the um
the thing to think about here is that
we're really making the problem a lot
simpler for each of the models that
we're composing together so it's a lot
simpler to have one text classification
model the jerk tries to decide whether
crime is being discussed then to
replicate that information across and
kind of adjoin it into the entity
classifications and so instead of trying
to decide at each of these things that
okay is this a crime location as well as
whether it's a crime we can factor that
the information away from each other
and that is going to make the the
annotations a lot easier to both
annotate and for a model to recognize
and it will likely take much less
annotation to do this if you compose it
this way so there's still extra logic it
has to be performed to I say figure out
that this person is actually the victim
of the crime as opposed to a perpetrator
or some incidental person but we
do this with other annotations and other
rule-based processes as well so I here's
a quick look at so many annotations that
Spacey producers that are not problem
dependent so these are sort of generic
information that's added as well so here
we conceded Alex Smith is annotated as a
passive subject of stabbed in other
words he's the person who was stabbed
and that grammatical relation there is
link there so we could have an extra
sort of process that says okay something
like stab and we can build up a lexicon
of these sort of victim words and we can
then have a rule-based process it says
okay if we've got that sort of crime act
and then you take the subject of it
that's going to be the victim in the
crime now I don't want to commit to you
know one specific plan for these things
because the point is that it does have
to be experimental but I hope you can
see that there's a lot of choices here
and making the correct choices on all of
these things is not trivial so the
correct answer is not to decide
everything upfront assumer or right and
start collecting lots of annotations we
need to start iterating and start seeing
what works for any specific problem and
that's going to in general yield a much
better you have much better results if
we take this sort of iterative approach
so as I I said here to sort of take-home
message here is that we often want to be
composing generic models into novel
solutions so we can have a generic
categories like location in person and
this lets you use pre-trained models
like Spacey provides and then fine
tuning those pre-trained models on your
domain is a lot lot cheaper than
creating annotation data for new
categories and in particular you don't
have this risk of making new categories
that then you have to refine later and
then you have to throw out all the data
that you annotated before so life is a
lot simpler if you can rely on generic
categories much more than trying to come
up with your own and then additionally
if you have things like events or topics
and things like this sort of semantic
information I've suggested you usually
think about annotating this at a
sentence or paragraph or document level
rather than trying to fix it to specific
phrases and the
reason is that if you do disses phrase
annotations you very often have
indeterminacies about the boundaries of
these things and especially if the
language gets even slightly metaphorical
trying to figure out exactly which word
in a sentence encodes that a crime was
committed ends up being super hard so if
you want it to be something like you
know okay I just want to know is it
about a crime you really shouldn't try
to put that at the word level you should
put it at the sentence or paragraph
level and then if you do that the the
annotation is easier the the
classification is more consistent and
easier to learn and then you can combine
the whole these pieces of information to
produce the solutions that you're
interested in um similarly if you want
something that a sort of like semantic
roles are like the person who did
something versus the person who didn't
and you can annotate those things by
single words and then use the syntactic
and a pass to get the boundaries around
that so you're basically sort of like
having a grid that you're snapping the
phrases to and this makes sure that your
boundaries always make sense okay so
here's a quick look at how this ends up
looking how does sort of workflow looks
with your using our tool set so The
Prodigy annotation tool gives you a few
commands that you can basically use to
start a little web service locally and
you give it a name of a data set and
it's going to save that in a little a
database locally by default we use
SQLite to sort of save you from
installing extra software and then you
can give it an input data file which is
you know by default was formatted in
Jason l it can also read from standard
input and you give it a label that you
might want to annotate so in this case
you're going to be get this feed of data
and you can just basically click through
whether it's a crime or not and so this
is super quick because you're just
annotating these short pieces of text
like a sentence and applying a binary
label so it's pretty normal to be you
know making one of these decisions every
5 to 10 seconds or so because you
basically have this really simple
decision to make and that means that you
can annotate the data set for that very
quickly and you can build up just enough
records to see whether how accurate that
model will be and how simple the
the task will be very quickly like you
know less than an hour of work and you
can have an initial result similarly we
have this teach recipe that lets you
improve the accuracy of pre train
categories so you know you can feed in a
label like personal location and if
there's an initial model that can make
those decisions like for instance Spacey
it provides you can just use this to
sort of fine-tune the accuracy so it
also you can tell it whether the models
right or wrong and it will train from
that and basically update its accuracy
on this then as a next process given all
of the annotations that you've provided
so far you can run batch training and
you know basically see how the accuracy
doesn't try out different hyper
parameters and you can do this Vinny NER
as well and then the output of all of
this is essentially just a model that
you can feed into Spacey I so the
spacing NOP library lets you just power
load this up and then you just get
basically this function that converts
text into the stock object and the dock
object that makes the annotation is easy
to access so you can do dr. dents and
you know assuming everything was correct
you'll get something like Alex Smith
Rhys London and these will have the
labels that you are interested in
attached so Alex Smith hopefully will be
labeled as a person
East London hopefully will be labeled as
a location and then you also get this
there's a text categorization so that's
accessible at dock cats and that will
tell you then it was a crime with you
know ninety percent certainty or
something like that so the whole
workflow here is pretty simple and
importantly we it's very useful to make
sure that it's outputting a model in the
form that you can then easily plug
forward into your production system so
that you can start trying this out in
the context replication and sort of both
sanity check it and start seeing what
would be useful and what isn't so you
you know basically try to avoid spending
too long in the single sandbox or too
long in any one step of that iterative
process if we can iterate over the hall
all the steps quicker then we can sort
of loop back around then sort of
progressively improve it so rather than
spending you know investing huge amounts
in an annotation
project or design project you start
getting evidence quicker and you know
it's really follows the same sort of
logic as
other development things where the
waterfall methodology is it tends to
perform worse if there's uncertainty and
having a sort of rapid iterative
approach so and that really feeds into
the second problem that I'm basically
going to highlight here and that's that
if you really only have an annotation
process that's designed for big
annotation projects and you're only
thinking about how to scale up and how
to collect tons of data because you
assume that that's what you need then
your time the first bit of evidence is
going to be very large and the
investment that you need to start
collecting some bit of evidence is going
to be very high and that's going to be a
real problem because you're going to
design this whole big annotation process
around assumptions which later may be on
ideal so instead of just we want a much
more fine-grained approach where you can
scale down and get much so and you can
start basing your assumptions on contact
with data and evidence so we want an
easy way to get say 200 annotations that
you can run an easy process we want a
process where you can have say you know
do one hour of work and get a meaningful
like insight into what you should do
next and in order to schedule the next
five hours of works that you can change
over the next 20 hours of work etc and
you can always be some building
bootstrapping that forward based on you
know contact with the data and evidence
instead of just guesses about what might
work and this is good because of that
fundamental uncertainty that we have
around this so if you just make guesses
you're very likely to be wrong and
that's why you know having a process
that scales down as well as a process
that scales up is so important and so
you know the prescription that we have
here is that you know basically even as
a data scientist yourself you know your
job isn't just to you know flow your
tenses and design models you should be
doing these annotation projects
initially yourself and that is going to
give you a much better insight into
what's likely to work so as part of your
sort of daily workflow having tooling
that makes it easy to start annotating
data to evaluate your ideas and start if
you have a new idea about you know
artist product my you know a new machine
learning powered feature might work in
this product or business process instead
of sort of colouring management and
putting everybody in a room to schedule
a meeting to barrack for your case you
can just
start trying it out and you can start
seeing whether you're right that some
approach is tractable that there's some
model will work and this is going to be
ultimately much more productive even
though it feels like Oh wasting time
I'm annotating it's much more productive
than having an idea for you know
widening your hidden layers and like you
know coding that up and then waiting for
that to Train etc the the real good
leverage point is going to be in the way
that you design the the way that you
break down the problem into different
machine learning models and so if you
spend much longer you know basically
figure out you know that you're
annotating the correct things and
structuring the project correctly you're
going to have a much better chance of
success a final tip that I would
recommend is this sort of a bare
valuation and so this is really a trick
that lets you do fine-grained evaluation
without a huge evaluation set 10 2010
okay cool so so what I mean by this is
normally if you're you know let's say
you're interested in figuring out
whether some model is 90 percent
accurate of ninety-one percent accurate
well in order to sort of figure out that
one percent of accuracy you probably
need to base that decision on about ten
examples so you need about a thousand
and it had examples to sort of reliably
guess that you know one percent
sensitivity well if instead of that we
do a B evaluation we can actually do
that much easier so this is what the a B
evaluation looks like it to looks like
in prodigy and actually it's especially
good for generative outputs we're having
a fixed evaluation set is not even very
tractable so imagine that we have this
an image captioning problem and so we
have this image and we want to know
which of these two outputs is better and
so imagine that we've got two models
that we're trying to evaluate and
compare and so one of them is told us
that this is a pug in a blanket on the
grass and the other one has told us to
do it's an unhappy child in the garden
so clearly the we want to say that this
one's better and so if we randomly
shuffle the order of our system outputs
we can basically just you know Abe
evaluate this and through a few hundred
times and we can do that very quickly
and this means that even if the models
are only slightly different if they're
outputting the same thing we get to skip
the example and so you're right and
you're very directly saying are this one
or that one is better and that means
that even if you're only making a small
tweak you can probably evaluate it
yourself in about ten or twenty minutes
you don't need a huge evaluation set to
do this now of course this isn't as
repeatable as a huge evaluation set and
so eventually you do want a sort of
stable consistent evaluation but when
you're scaling down and you just want to
you know basically be more nimble this
is the a/b evaluation is a good approach
for a lot of things and again it gives
you a good evaluation even on generative
outputs instead of relying on some
nonsense like a blur score or something
okay
so then a final problem that we that I
want to highlight is that you know even
the way to people actually approach
adaptation is often pretty bad and we
summarized this problem by saying that
it's hard to get good data by boring the
[ __ ] out of underpaid people and so if
you just put your tasks onto Amazon
Mechanical Turk there's a whole lot of
intermediate problems that you have to
solve to actually make sure that you're
going you get quality annotations that
you can learn from and if you don't
immediately get quality annotations that
you can learn from
it's very hard to inter interpret the
results and inspect whether the data was
wrong or your model is wrong or like the
annotation scheme was wrong because
there's too many explanations for what
for the problem so I would suggest that
processes like Mechanical Turk or other
outsourcing based processes that are
designed to drive the end of the
marginal cost or of new annotation
towards zero are actually mostly solving
the wrong problem on what you want is a
time to first data set and the and a
protest it's going to be reliable rather
than trying to see it as okay how how
much can we pay for individual
annotation the overhead is actually
something that matters a lot more and so
I actually think that for most
situations having a small annotation
team working consistently with a good
workflow and good communication with
data scientists is usually going to give
you better results and in particular
reframing your problems so that you'll
break them down into smaller pieces so
that the annotator has to consider less
at a time it's also very product
if so the insight here is that the
annotators don't need to have a workflow
did exactly match this the way that the
model works so even if the annotators
are sort of seeing sort of pre suggested
output a pre fueled output and the model
won't that's probably going to be fine
and in fact it often makes the
annotation more accurate to have it
semi-automatic because if you try to
have somebody constantly make the same
decision a thousand times in a row it's
very likely that they're going to have
some reliability errors and they're
going to have some make some errors that
machine never would so for instance if
you're tagging parts of speech you
pretty much don't want to have a human
and I take every instance of that as an
mark that is a determiner because
they're going to be wrong sometimes and
when they're wrong they're probably
going to really confuse the model
whereas if you do that semi
automatically and they only have to you
know basically correct this when it's
wrong you're going to have actually more
consistent annotations finally also
actually suggested doing annotation
in-house and having is good for lots of
reasons and not least of which is data
privacy because you don't have this sort
of third-party provider problem who
probably wants to be clever and
outsource the data themselves and so
then the text which you know maybe say
user feedback on your product or you
know text that was uploaded into your
platform or user messages and things
might be getting out to some arbitrary
number of people which even before you
know sensible regulations were
introduced I actually think is something
that people should definitely worry
about and it's like you know not a good
look for anybody so to wrap this up the
solution to this chicken and egg problem
is iteration so you know basically and
this sort of makes deep sense right like
if you can't solve the problem
analytically we have to solve it
iteratively like if we can't reason from
you know if you've got this sort of
circular dependency and we want to sort
of progressively estimate all of these
things well we have to just start make
an initial estimate and start feeding
that forward and then progressively
iterate on this and you know in the same
way that we would do this in to you know
basically in a machine learning solution
I think the same actually works here
it's you know a fundamental thing about
the knowledge being float float around
and
the the fact that there's this sort of
dependency structure means it actually
this is a satisfying approach so thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks very much Matt for a very nice
talk
are there any questions in the audience
over here thanks for your talk
I just have one question about the
screenshot that you display there abouts
Pacey it's able to detect the tax as
crime is it come automatically from
spacy or you make some adjustment on it
so you maybe fit the label on it okay so
I'll just go back to the slide just so
that we have grounding of what we're
talking about so the the process here of
the dispatch train and that's outputting
a text classification model that can
then sort of feed into the spacy
pipeline and so that sits in the space
pipeline and it has the job of taking
dock objects and attaching making
predictions based on its neural network
model and in touching those predictions
into the dr. Katz's process so you can
actually you know you could for instance
write an arbitrary function that had
that job and it added to the pipeline or
you could write your own machine
learning model but the built-in text
categorization system that's basically
provides users an ensemble of the
convolutional neural network and a bag
of words model and then Prodigy trains
this and it outputs it into the model
for spacy to use so I think the label is
in your data set and so the label the
label crime comes in here where we label
this and we do this text cut teach that
creates the training data then in this
step we train from the training data
outputting a model we use that model as
the input into this in our batch
training process and that carries
forward the text cut model into the full
model that's output here and then we
load the full model and that's how to be
data flows around ok yes in the back
yes certainly
okay yeah you said someone like you may
be experts on pillai extract the victim
and maybe also the murderer of a crime
and for that you said maybe use the
dependency parcel but the dependency
parser tends to someone get considerably
worse if someone like your corpus has a
different structure than and then the de
penser people was originally trained on
so normally dependency parser has an
accuracy of mighty three percent or
something like that but i can I see
often that it gets down to something
like sixty percent on something like
very different colloquial speech so how
would you treat a problem like that so
this is definitely a concern and in
particular I would say that it's often
hard to reason about or have had the
guess how useful the dependency paths
will be before you start trying things
out so if it is the case that you'd like
to use this and the accuracy isn't high
enough having this sort of training
process where you you know basically
improving the accuracy of it on your
domain is something that we we
definitely see a solution going forward
so the dependency sort of recipes in
prodigy are still a little bit in beta
form but you can really use this to you
know start making some corrections to
the dependency parser if it is the case
that the dependency parser doesn't do
what you want then actually having
another model that is basically only
constrained to work on the person
category I would say is probably going
to be a better approach so in other
words you could classify only two person
entities and apply some sort of more
specific model based on that for whether
it is victim another option would be did
you might have a sort of fixed number of
frames that you know basically predicate
argument structures followed you know
shapes at which there's sort of these
relationships between victim perpetrator
etc and if that's the case then you can
classify this you can tag the sentence
with those things instead of relying on
the dependency parsers features finally
I
you can also reduce the sentence and
train your own sort of little paws tree
over just the sentence just the input
pieces which were useful so you
basically get just use the tree building
technology and train that yourself and
because that's working on such a reduced
problem level and you can abstract the
English so much that may also be easy to
trial may also be easy to train so
there's a few there's a sort of range of
options that you can sort of think about
an explore that will depend on the
specific to the problem that I would
definitely say that it's not something
where you just know ahead of time that
like I this is the one way to do it
let's invest everything in this you
should you know explore these things
need to write yes
hi so you mentioned a dependency parser
recipe do you do you see a more
generically just link prediction recipe
in the future so you can you can
definitely use the tooling there for
sort of more generic link annotations
the only sort of coupling with the
recipe dairies that you know we wanted
to have the pre train model there and
you know have that sort of suggesting
the links and things so the because the
pre train models that we provide do you
know basically this syntactic structure
there's a question of how you will sort
of get the initial suggestions if you're
doing it that way
but if you have some process that
basically suggests links for you you can
certainly just type those into prodigy
and say yes or no to them and that's no
problem we have time for one last
question but over there I think that was
first sir
so I have a question in terms of the
features that currently you guys are
looking at which is very focused on the
text is there any focus towards other
types of features that may be in the
either visual or positional or
formatting sense when processing things
like documents or or images with text
are you guys looking to also use space
you're one of these frameworks to be
able to extract these features and
unload them and be able to analyze them
even with with prodigy like PDFs etc
yeah so just has come up a bit over the
last few months and so it's definitely
something we've been thinking about I
think this the solution that I think is
probably best is that you feed the the
output of say a more you know text
focused model forward as features into a
downstream model which combines
information from different sources so
you know as an example of the type of
thing which is coming up people might
have want to do named entity recognition
there's some metadata attached to the
article or something like you know maybe
topic categories or something like this
and they want to use those features to
improve the accuracy of the antidiuretic
mission which is you know a very
reasonable thing to want to do so rather
than having a general purpose way of
putting those features into the entity
recognition model and kind of trying to
retrain with new features I think it's
actually better to do it
somebody inverse and take the output of
the entity recognition model and feed
that forward into a next level model and
I think that'll make it easier to for us
to you know be providing something which
is reusable across different things and
also that you can sort of really write
arbitrary features yourself rather than
having to be limited to whatever feature
API we ended up trying to expose to make
a compromise for that so I think that
that's probably the best way to to make
that happen let's thank our speaker Ian
you